Minister sajan can I ask you about the
situation in turkey and what Canada is
planning to do to help first of all a
condolence
and the loved ones who've been affected
by the
um uh Kendall will be committing at the
initial 10 million for the initial
response
um and we're conducting A needs
assessment to look at what will be the
next steps more details will be provided
on this shortly but I also want to
emphasize that when any time the
disaster strikes Canada actually funds
the UN for when it comes to their
Disaster Assistance or response teams
two teams have already been deployed to
start conducting the needs assessment
we're also looking at various other
options or Medical Teams heavier Urban
search and rescue and I know that also
Minister none is looking at options for
the dart as well so no Canadian teams at
this point we're right now we have to
conduct the assessments but to figure
out you know all that information has to
be kind of worked out nothing's off the
table uh so but we'll look at any
options when it comes to uh disasters
like this and and uh when we have to
respond very quickly we have to look we
work on uh well-established
organizations that can respond and once
we have an assessment of what the
situation is on the ground then we can
take a look at what all are the unique
needs now keep in mind a lot of the
earthquakes also taking place in Syria
where there is a civil war going on and
we're very mindful of this uh
fortunately
um we had already authorized 50 million
dollars for humanitarian support in
Syria early on even before the
earthquake and fortunately this money
now now can at least start flowing uh to
the population there but we'll also take
a look at options of what we can do in
Syria but through the red crescent there
we will be able to provide support I
don't know if you know this but also one
of the cities that were affected a
gasoline type I don't have the
pronunciation right is actually a un
humanitarian Hub so supplies are already
starting to flow we're also looking at
ARC
Canadian hubs as well one in Dubai in
Mississauga and what we can provide but
we'll be working today to look at the
assessment and and look at what more we
can provide any considerations
are you are you worried about the aid
money getting to where it needs to go in
Syria especially charity Aid groups have
raised concerns about that no that's a
very good point in fact actually this is
one of the reasons why
um uh when we in any type of criticism
we are very mindful of where the money
goes and where why we want to work with
trusted organizations that have a good
track record to provide the support so
that's something we're very mindful of
and to answer your question about a
matching fund yes we actually are
considering just looking at the options
right now do you have any idea how long
this assessment will take and when can
it will be able to start oh we're this
is where anytime like this is ongoing in
fact actually just from yesterday from
the assessments this is one of the
reasons why we came up with the initial
10 million normally for disasters we're
actually usually we start a little bit
lower but given the magnitude based on
the feedback we were getting why we're
actually going higher once we have more
uh we'll be able to move very quickly
I'll be contacting the various heavier
Urban search and rescue teams and take a
look at what we can deploy uh in fact
actually this is something that we're
already looking uh in terms of capacity
building training for very parts of the
uh of the world for uh for Disaster
Response
um so look first of all uh this is an
absolute disaster that's playing here in
turkey and Syria uh I've had the chance
to connect with some members of my
community uh perhaps most notably uh
Tara Cadet who's become very well known
as a successful a newcomer to Canada
after uh fleeing very challenging
circumstances in Syria they're
absolutely devastating to see a scenario
play out like this uh demands that the
whole world think of what they can do of
course in 48 hours to put together plans
to respond when you're dealing with an
immigration system that over the course
of Canada's history has been designed to
respond to massive displacement over a
series of years not a matter of hours
you can appreciate it may take some time
to formulate the appropriate response
understanding whether a natural disaster
like this will actually cause a
migration crisis remains to be seen but
of course we watch very closely and I
should say not only immigration point of
view but also Global Affairs and
International Development to figure out
what the the best response may be so as
it stands now we're watching the
situation very closely but we need to
better understand the Dynamics from a
migration point of view before we
understand what the best path forward